How do you feel about mistletoe and B-17?
So B-17 is, my name is B-17, also known as leantral.
So I'm a big fan of both mistletoe and B-17.
You know, so those are two different things that can be used for cancer.
So B-17 is an oxidized agent. That's how it works.
So it could be coupled with just about any other therapy.
Mistletoe works on a totally different principle.
It's not actually mistletoe that's killing cancer at all.
Mistletoe is just a hyperimmune stimulant in how it works.
So when you're doing either mistletoe IV or mistletoe injection,
the whole purpose of it is your mistletoe is an irritant.
It's an irritant to your immune system.
It's a very strong irritant to your immune system.
And what it does is it stimulates an immune response.
So it stimulates this huge cytopide response.
So it can stimulate a TH1 immune system response.
So it can be great for cancer.
So I am all four of these things that they can be great therapies.
I tried some last year and I reacted with a huge lump.
So I don't know. We're talking about mistletoe.
I mean, mistletoe injections, the whole...
How you know it's working is that you're creating this inflammatory process.
You should get this big red spot on your belly when you do that injection.
That's... If you don't, then you don't have the right dose.
You want to get it to the dose where you're getting this great big red spot.
And it can be even irritant. It can... It should feel hot.
You might not feel well.
That's how it works.
So... But I may try it again and try other kinds.
This would be a trust con for the ability to do this.
So I want you to know how you feel about this.
So I think those are fine options.
I don't have anything against those whatsoever.